In the sweltering heat of July 1825,
President Jean-Pierre Buouyet of Haiti
stood in the presidential palace in
Porto Prince, staring at a document that
would determine the fate of his nation
for generations.
Outside in the harbor, 14 French
warships sat with their cannons trained
on the city, their hulls dark against
the Caribbean sky.
The messenger who had delivered the
ultimatum stood silent in the corner,
watching the president's hands tremble
as he read the terms.
This was not a negotiation. It was a
robbery dressed in the language of
diplomacy, and Ber knew that every word
on that paper was written in the blood
of his people.
The French crown was demanding
150 million Franks in gold as
compensation for the loss of their
richest colony.
They called it an indemnity for the
property seized during the revolution,
property that included the enslaved
human beings who had freed themselves.
The calculation was cold and obscene.
Each Frank represented the estimated
value of a plantation. a sugar mill, a
coffee press, and most grotesqually, the
monetary worth of the half million
enslaved people who had fought for their
freedom. The French accountants had
tallied up the cost of liberation and
sent Haiti a bill for winning its own
independence.
Boyer had 5 days to accept or the
warships would begin the bombardment.
The entire nation, barely two decades
old, hung between capitulation and
annihilation.
Hades path to this moment of extortion
began on the night of August 22nd, 1791,
when enslaved people in the northern
province rose up against their masters
in the most successful slave rebellion
in human history.
For 13 brutal years, the revolutionaries
fought against the armies of France,
Spain, and Britain. Enduring yellow
fever, starvation, and the scorched
earth tactics of European powers
determined to crush the uprising.
They defeated Napoleon's most
experienced generals, men who had
conquered half of Europe by using
guerilla warfare and the knowledge of
their own terrain. On January 1st, 184,
Jean Jacqu Deselene declared Haiti
independent, the first black republic in
the world and the only nation born from
a successful slave revolt. But freedom,
they would discover, came with a price
that would be extracted over and over
again.
The new nation was immediately isolated
by the global powers who feared that the
example of Haiti would inspire slave
rebellions throughout the Americas,
the United States refused to recognize
Hades independence for nearly 60 years.
Terrified that the virus of black
liberation would spread to its own
enslaved population,
France, humiliated by the military
defeat, imposed a trade embargo that
strangled Hades economy.
European banks refused to lend money to
the rebel nation. The international
community built an invisible wall around
Haiti, ensuring that its experiment in
black self-governance would be starved
of capital, trade, and diplomatic
legitimacy.
By 1825, Haiti had survived as an
independent nation, but it was
economically suffocating, and France
knew it.
King Charles I 10th of France, a
reactionary monarch who had recently
ascended to the throne, saw an
opportunity to restore some measure of
French honor and fill his treasury.
He dispatched Baron de Macau with a
fleet of warships and a demand for
compensation that was dressed up in the
rhetoric of fairness.
The French argued that the former
colonists, many of whom had fled to
France after the revolution, deserved to
be compensated for the loss of their
estates.
These colonists had been living in Paris
and other French cities, bitter and
impoverished, demanding that the crown
restore their fortunes.
The French government decided that Haiti
should pay for the restoration.
It was a breathtaking act of imperial
arrogance, demanding that the victims of
slavery compensate their former
enslavers for the inconvenience of
losing their human property. President
Buer was trapped in an impossible
calculus. If he refused, the French
would bombard Porto Prince and likely
invade, returning Haiti to colonial
servitude or worse, triggering a
bloodbath that would destroy the fragile
institutions of the young republic.
If he accepted, Haiti would be saddled
with a debt so massive that it would
consume the nation's resources for
decades.
Boyet was not a revolutionary fire brand
like Desolines or Tusan Luvetur.
He was a pragmatist, a politician who
had risen through the military ranks and
believed in negotiation and stability.
He looked at the warships in the harbor
and he calculated the cost of
resistance.
He believed he was choosing the survival
of the nation, but he was actually
signing away its future.
On July 11th, 1825,
Buer issued a proclamation accepting the
French terms. He announced to the
Haitian people that in exchange for
French recognition of Hades
independence, the nation would pay 150
million Franks in five annual
installments.
The proclamation tried to frame the
agreement as a victory, emphasizing that
France had finally recognized Haiti as a
sovereign nation.
But the Haitian people understood the
bitter truth. They had fought for their
freedom with blood and had won it on the
battlefield.
Now they were being forced to buy that
same freedom again with gold. It was the
most expensive retroactive ransom in
history. A debt imposed not for money
borrowed but for the crime of liberating
themselves.
The scale of the indemnity was
staggering beyond comprehension.
150 million Franks was roughly 10 times
Hades annual revenue at the time. It was
more than the amount the United States
had paid France for the entire Louisiana
purchase. Two decades earlier, a
transaction that transferred 828,000
square miles of territory, Haiti, a
small Caribbean nation still recovering
from the devastation of war, was being
asked to pay an amount that exceeded the
value of a continental empire.
The French had designed the debt to be
unpayable,
a permanent shackle that would keep
Haiti in a state of economic servitude.
To meet the terms, Haiti would have to
borrow money from French banks at
extortionate interest rates, creating a
cycle of debt that would spiral for
generations.
Boyer's government immediately began the
brutal work of extraction. They imposed
new taxes on the already impoverished
population, taxing coffee, sugar, and
every export that left the island. They
cut spending on education,
infrastructure, and public health,
redirecting every available frank toward
the debt payment. Haitian farmers who
had just begun to cultivate small plots
of land for themselves were now taxed so
heavily that they could barely survive.
The promise of the revolution that the
land would belong to those who worked it
was betrayed by the need to pay France.
The entire economy was reorganized
around servicing the debt.
Haiti [snorts] became a extraction
machine, funneling its wealth to Paris
to compensate the descendants of slave
owners. But even with these brutal
measures, Haiti could not meet the
payment schedule.
The French banks, eager to profit from
Hades desperation, offered loans with
interest rates that ranged from
impossible to predatory.
Haiti borrowed money from French
financiers to pay the French government,
creating a double extraction.
The banks charged interest that
compounded year after year so that even
as Haiti made payments, the total amount
owed continued to grow.
It was a debt trap designed with
mathematical precision, a financial
noose that tightened with every payment.
By the mid-9th century, Haiti was
spending roughly 80% of its national
budget on debt service, leaving almost
nothing for roads, schools, hospitals,
or the basic functions of government.
The human cost of the debt was measured
in lost generations. Haitian children
grew up without schools because there
was no money for teachers.
Haitian farmers worked land that
produced wealth that immediately left
the country, flowing to French banks and
French creditors.
The country that had been the richest
colony in the Americas, producing more
wealth than all 13 American colonies
combined before the revolution was now
trapped in grinding poverty.
The fertile soil that had made French
plantation owners immensely rich was
still productive, but the profits no
longer stayed in Haiti.
They were siphoned off to Paris, payment
for a debt that was rooted in the
immorality of slavery itself.
If you're still here watching this
moment when a nation was forced to pay
for its own freedom, if you believe that
financial exploitation can be as
devastating as military conquest, go
ahead and like this video and comment
the word justice below.
Let's see how many of us recognize that
debt can be a weapon as brutal as any
cannon. In 1838,
under immense pressure and facing the
reality that the original terms were
destroying Haiti, the French government
agreed to reduce the debt to 90 million
francs.
It was presented as an act of
generosity, a concession to Haiti
suffering, but it was nothing of the
sort.
The reduction still left Haiti with a
debt larger than its economy could
sustain. And the French insisted that
the reduction would only take effect if
Haiti agreed to preferential trade terms
that gave French merchants priority
access to Haitian markets. Once again,
Haiti was forced to choose between bad
options. They accepted the reduction
because the alternative was complete
financial collapse. But the debt
remained an anchor, dragging the nation
into deeper poverty.
The decades that followed saw Haiti
convulsed by political instability, much
of it driven by the economic desperation
created by the debt.
Presidents rose and fell, often
violently as different factions fought
for control of the meager resources that
remained. After debt payments, foreign
powers, particularly the United States,
began to see Haiti as a strategic
interest and a financial opportunity.
American banks started to offer loans to
Haiti, not out of charity, but because
they saw a chance to replace French
creditors and gain influence over the
island. The debt became
internationalized,
spreading from Paris to New York,
entangling Haiti in a web of foreign
financial control.
By the early 20th century, Hades
finances were in chaos. The country had
borrowed from so many different sources
at so many different interest rates that
the government had lost track of exactly
how much it owed and to whom. In 1915,
using the pretext of political
instability and debt default, the United
States invaded Haiti and occupied the
country.
American Marines landed in Porto Prince
and seized control of the government,
the banks, and the customs houses.
One of their first acts was to
consolidate Hades debts, taking control
of the revenue streams that had been
pledged to foreign creditors.
The American occupation would last for
19 years, during which Haiti sovereignty
was suspended and its economy was
managed by foreign officials who
prioritize debt repayment above all
else.
During the occupation, American
officials forced Haiti to rewrite its
constitution to allow foreign ownership
of land, breaking one of the sacred
principles of the Haitian Revolution.
American corporations moved in to
establish plantations, recreating a
system that resembled the very slavery
that Haitians had fought to escape.
The debt, meanwhile, continued to grow
as Haiti borrowed money to pay off old
loans and to fund the costs of the
occupation itself.
The cruel irony was inescapable. Haiti
was paying for the privilege of being
occupied, funding the military force
that had stripped away its independence.
The original French debt had
metastasized into a comprehensive system
of foreign economic control. When the
Americans finally withdrew in 1934,
they left behind a Haiti that was even
more deeply indebted and more
politically fractured than before.
The debt to France, the debt to American
banks, and the debt incurred during the
occupation combined into a crushing
burden that defined Hades economic
reality.
Haitian governments desperate for
revenue continued to borrow, often on
terrible terms, simply to keep the state
functioning.
Each new loan was justified as necessary
for development, for infrastructure, for
stability.
But in practice, most of the borrowed
money went straight back out of the
country to service old debts.
Haiti was running on a treadmill,
exhausting itself just to stay in place.
It was not until 1947,
122 years after the original indemnity
was imposed, that Haiti made its final
payment on the debt to France. By that
time, the original 150 million Franks,
reduced to 90 million, had ballooned
through interest and additional loans to
a sum that exceeded $21 billion in
today's currency when calculated with
cumulative economic impact.
The wealth that Haiti had transferred to
France over more than a century
represented the entire developmental
potential of the nation. It was money
that could have built universities,
hospitals, roads, and industries.
Instead, it went to compensate the
people who had once owned human beings.
But even the final payment in 1947
did not free Haiti from the legacy of
the debt.
The economic structures that had been
built to service the indemnity, the
reliance on foreign loans, the
extraction of agricultural surplus, the
neglect of infrastructure and education.
All of these had become embedded in the
fabric of Haitian society.
The country had been shaped by the debt,
its institutions warped by the need to
pay, its people conditioned to expect
that the wealth they produced would
leave the island.
The debt had ended, but the poverty it
created had become self-perpetuating.
The psychological and political impact
of the double debt was perhaps even more
devastating than the financial cost.
Haiti had been forced to accept the
premise that its freedom was
illegitimate, that the act of liberating
oneself from slavery was a crime that
required restitution.
This premise, accepted under the threat
of violence in 1825,
became internalized over generations.
It sent a message to Haiti and to the
world that black self-determination came
with a price. That former slaves could
not simply claim their freedom, but had
to purchase it from their former
masters. It was a doctrine designed to
delegitimize the Haitian Revolution and
to ensure that no other enslaved
population would dare to follow Hades
example.
The story of the Haitian indemnity is
not a footnote in history.
It is a case study in how financial
instruments can be used as weapons of
imperial control just as effectively as
armies and navies. France did not need
to reconquer Haiti militarily. They
conquered it economically using debt as
a tool to extract wealth and ensure
dependence.
The mechanics of the debt trap, the
impossible terms, the compounding
interest, the forced borrowing to meet
payments would be replicated in
different forms across the colonized
world in the 20th century.
International financial institutions
would use similar techniques demanding
structural adjustment and austerity in
exchange for loans perpetuating cycles
of poverty in the name of fiscal
responsibility.
For Haiti, the consequences of the
double debt are visible today in every
measure of human development.
The country ranks near the bottom of
global indexes for health, education,
and economic opportunity.
Its infrastructure is fragile, its
institutions weak, its people resilient,
but trapped in a cycle of poverty that
has deep historical roots.
Natural disasters like the earthquake of
2010 reveal the vulnerability that was
built into Hades foundation by more than
a century of resource extraction.
The lack of hospitals, the absence of
building codes, the weakness of the
state. All of these can be traced back
to the choices that were forced on Haiti
in 1825
and the decades that followed.
In recent years, there have been calls
for France to repay the money that Haiti
was forced to transfer, to recognize the
indemnity as an act of extortion and to
provide reparations for the damage it
caused.
French officials have resisted, arguing
that the debts were legal agreements
made by sovereign governments and that
modern France cannot be held responsible
for the actions of the monarchy.
But the legal argument misses the moral
reality.
The debt was imposed at gunpoint. It was
rooted in the legitimization of slavery
and it violated every principle of
justice.
To say that it was legal is simply to
acknowledge that the international
system of the 19th century was designed
to protect the interests of imperial
powers at the expense of colonized and
formerly enslaved peoples.
The economic historians who have studied
the Haitian indemnity estimate that if
Haiti had been able to invest the money
it paid to France into its own
development, the country would be
unrecognizable today.
The compounded value of that lost
investment calculated over nearly two
centuries runs into the hundreds of
billions of dollars.
It represents schools that were never
built, roads that were never paved,
industries that were never developed,
and generations of Haitians who lived
and died in poverty that was not
inevitable but was imposed.
The counterfactual history, the Haiti
that could have been, stands as an
accusation against the logic of debt as
domination.
President Buer died in 1850, living just
long enough to see the beginnings of the
misery that his decision had created.
History has judged him harshly in Haiti,
seen by many as the man who sold the
nation's future to avoid a fight. But
Ber's choice was not made in a vacuum.
He was facing an empire with warships
and the willingness to use them. and he
was leading a nation that was exhausted,
isolated, and desperate for recognition.
His tragedy was that he believed the
promise of the international order that
if Haiti played by the rules, if it
accepted the terms of the powerful, it
would be allowed to prosper. He learned
too late that the rules were designed to
ensure that prosperity would flow in
only one direction.
The legacy of the double debt extends
beyond Haiti to every nation that has
struggled under the weight of
illegitimate and odious debt. It raises
fundamental questions about the morality
of debt contracts, about who decides
what is owed and what is fair, and about
the mechanisms of international finance
that allow powerful nations and
institutions to perpetuate inequality
across generations.
The Haitian indemnity was not an
anomaly. It was a template. It showed
that you do not need chains and whips to
maintain control over a population. You
just need a ledger, a contract, and the
willingness to enforce payment by any
means necessary.
In the end, Haiti paid for its freedom
twice.
First in the blood of the revolution
when hundreds of thousands died fighting
for the right to be free. and then in
gold, transferring the wealth of
generations to the people who had once
enslaved them.
It was the most expensive freedom in
human history, and the cost is still
being paid today in the poverty and
suffering of the Haitian people. The
double debt stands as a monument to the
cruelty of empire and the long shadow
that historical injustice casts across
the present. When we look at Haiti
today, we should see not just a poor
country struggling with instability, but
a nation that was systematically robbed
of its future by the very powers that
claim to represent civilization and
progress.
We should recognize that the poverty of
Haiti is not a natural condition or a
cultural failure, but the direct result
of economic violence that was inflicted
deliberately and sustained over more
than a century.
And we should ask ourselves what justice
looks like for a crime that was
perpetrated by governments, sanctioned
by international law, and never
acknowledged or repaired.
The answer to that question will
determine whether we are truly committed
to a world where freedom is a right or
whether we still believe that some
people must pay for the privilege of
being human.